everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie it's been a few days it's been
kind of crazy
we had a big ice storm here and
everything was covered and I don't know
like this much ice it was wild
so the offices were closed yesterday I
had like unexpected things going on and
meetings getting moved around and so I
just didn't really have like I wasn't
confident that I would have enough time
to stream so today I'm gonna catch you
up with some of the things that I've
been doing some pool requests and then
we're gonna work a little bit on the
layout for the homepage so to understand
why I'm doing this let me tell you
what's what's been happening so I all
right let me how to try to start from
the beginning here okay so some people
higher up in the university that I work
for have decided that they don't want
the website to go live by the end of
this month which is what we were
shooting for we'll see if that stands
from from what I understand I wasn't
involved in any of these meetings but
from what I understand I think that
there's a misunderstanding here about
with this website kind of redesigned and
development is involving and I think
there's a fear that it's going to be
such a big change that prospective
students are going to be confused so now
I'm gonna have meetings with different
groups of people within the university
some different people you know higher up
in the university and I'm gonna demo
this website to them
show them what we're doing explain it my
hope is that after people see how far
along this is and and what we're
actually doing then they'll be okay with
us launching now if we have to push back
the launch date we have to but it's
going to cost you know the university
some extra money to renew the contract
for the old websites content management
system so I'd rather not push it back if
it's unnecessary if the reason we push
it back is simply because you know
there's a misunderstanding then that's
even if it's not that much money it's
still a waste you know it's a waste of
money so I'm gonna do what I can in
terms of the meetings but that changes
the plan a little bit for how we we
develop this so the plan right now is
get the homepage looking as good as
possible and as functional as possible
right away like within the next few days
well today and then the next few days of
next week's like Monday Tuesday
Wednesday I have to present it to the
first group on Thursday so I just leaves
us a few days and then also we want to
get as many interior pages as we can
looking good
so I can demo things so here's what I've
been doing to make that happen let me
switch over so I can show you on my
screen so we have this is kind of small
what if I can I can't really zoom in let
me take this out of the mobile view so
that I can just make it bigger of course
we're still doing kind of a mobile first
development but so this is one of the
things that I've added I know that one
of the people who is really concerned
probably the main person that is really
concerned about the launch date wants to
delay it it's also probably going to be
looking for this type of thing these
student profiles so I brought over some
student profiles and I made sure that
the images comes
and that some videos come through so
this is really basic we're gonna have to
do some styling on on this kind of thing
I don't like that look but overall it
came through it came through okay
I'll show you what I had I had to do
some stuff to get these to come through
all right now I'll show you more about
that but then also these links on the
side I've been adding in the URLs so
these will now actually link to the
right places the assuming that we have
the correct data so let me see alright
cool so that one did work these are
links and they also use the next link
prefetch so that next has a link
component built in and then we can add
prefetch so that should make the
transition between pages extra fast
that's another feature I want to really
show off is how fast this website is
compared to the old one it's going to be
fast compared to any website but
especially compared to the old one I
think that's a huge selling point and
maybe I'm going to bring in some
statistics on the likely number of
prospective students that are actually
leaving our current site before it even
loads because the load times are so
terrible and how many more students we
would have if we switch the site over so
if anyone has any other ideas of things
that I could bring up potentially in a
meeting to try to convince people that
this website should go live sooner
rather than later let me know thankfully
most of the people that are meeting with
I already know what their concerns are
so I have a good idea of how I want to
frame this there are some new people
that I haven't even met yet so that's
going to be kind of an unknown for me as
a you know kind of what what their
concerns are so let's see those are two
big things I've just been pulling over
more content and let's see
I guess let's go back to the homepage so
you can see the homepage has really like
nothing nothing changed from what we had
on it before I did I did change this a
little bit as you see there's a I don't
think we had this before but there's a
change in the color that's kind of like
another indicator of the hierarchy in
the menu I'm sure I'm missing a few
other things that happen oh we upgraded
to an even newer version of next and
that helps the the problem that we were
to solve on you know a few days ago that
helped to fix that problem so thank you
to harsh it for getting on the next
github repo and you're communicating
with the maintainer --zz alright so this
is going to be the first thing that the
people see when I I present this what
I'm thinking is that I'm gonna present
the mobile view first so I'm gonna have
on a projector my phone the screen on my
phone to show what this looks like and
then I'm also going to invite them to
view it on their phones which is a
little bit of a risk right because you
know maybe they have a really old phone
with an old outdated browser maybe it
looks weird but I think it would be nice
to have them actually be able to click
around I'm gonna invite them to try to
load the current website the really slow
one on their phone try to click around
on that just to get an idea of you know
just really kind of the difference in
the experience after that I will show
them the desktop version if they want to
see it but I want I really think that
their audience of high school students
is way more likely to view this on their
phone based on data that I've seen
unfortunately in Google Analytics the
lowest age group I can that it'll show
me is 18 to 24 year olds
that's not really a good group that's
that's not our target audience so that's
kind of like eighteen year olds our
target audience but we want eighteen in
below so I can't get actual analytics
data from our current site for that
audience but regardless I don't think
it'll be disputed that mobile is going
to be the primary means so assuming this
is the first thing people see one thing
we definitely need an image that fits of
the school we may or may not put that
image in today I don't really want to
spend time going through the photos that
we have on the stream I'd rather do some
code so we will be changing the image
just so you know these buttons will
probably remain the same for now what we
really need to do is scroll through and
just make sure what we got to put
something right here you know this first
section needs to grab attention so
that's that's my big thing you know
further down the page is becomes less
and less important but probably anything
like from here up we need to put
something you know special in those
those sections you know not only for the
end user which will be this perspective
students but for the meetings we need to
grab you'll grab the attention so I'm
thinking you know something like this
with a nice impressive quote is fine
potentially a video I think would be
good but I know that some of the people
that are going to be in these meetings
are going to want to see a student
profile so since we already brought in
the student profile data well I already
brought it in earlier today I think
that's what we should do is really try
to make a card or a section that
highlights current students and I mean I
don't know I guess maybe they found that
the prospective students really like to
see stories occurrence
so for whatever reason that's what we're
gonna show them so that's what we're
gonna work on first we're gonna try to
design and then develop as a react
component some element which we'll
showcase on a mobile screen an image a
name and then a little bit of
information about a student and we'll
provide a link to a page that has more
information maybe even a video so we
have some things that we could work from
right now like we were going to use this
this doesn't look good on mobile so
let's start out maybe we'll start from
here at least we'll have something and
then let's see how we can switch this
around to make it look make it look
better so now I think about it I don't
want to use this first this looks better
on desk desktop but I think something
like this would work better on a mobile
view all right let's start with that
let me read through the live chat really
quickly since I know there's it seems
like there's a lot a lot in the live
chat are ready hey everyone okay we I do
have some good advice for the meetings
here John Hanson says you have to push
the ease speed booze and AHS don't go
for the power under the hood Tech Talk
that's good advice
definitely I'm gonna have I'm gonna
really try to remember that to not talk
technology probably the only thing I'll
get into that is just simply there's
gonna be reliability and there's gonna
be no downtime when we update I don't
really need to get into why unless
somebody asks see juggernaut says Pete
speed is key 47% of customers expect a
website to
two seconds or less 40% of customers
will abandon a website that takes more
than three seconds to load that's
awesome those are the kind of statistics
that I really want to lead with
juggernaut says every second that
customers have to wait longer than three
seconds reduces their satisfaction by
16% 79% of customers who are
dissatisfied with website performance
are less likely to repeat the purchase
44 percent of online shoppers tell
friends and family about a bad online
shopping experience cool juggernaut if
you have a source for this like a link
or something please send that to me
because I like I want to use some of
these statistics but in case somebody
says where are you getting this info I'd
like to be able to point them you know
somewhere so if you do have that that'd
be great otherwise I'll probably spend
some time looking up sources myself just
to have it ready all right let's start
this timer let's let's start doing some
code well some design slash slash code
here right it kind of makes them
together alright so we're gonna be on
our index.html component let me start in
grok so you all can what was it already
started I guess I never shut off an
grukk it's been on for days
well not that anybody's really been on
it okay so try this link for n grow up
let me know if it doesn't work I assume
it's still gonna work but I don't know
that I've ever kept it on this long
looks like it's working awesome okay
where's our index page
let's make this a lot bigger okay so for
right now we're going to do everything
in the index page well obviously we want
to break this out into its own component
at some point well let's go down and
find a card let's see which one this one
all right you should be the second card
that we have here there we are okay so
let's just work with this card and start
to change it since we already have it
here what I'd like to do is grab let's
check out a student let's check out that
student page that I showed you at the
beginning so let's open a new tab low
blows nice there we go the student
profile so let's look at Noah Fisher
I've never met Noah Fisher don't really
know who Noah is but let's take Noah's
stuff here so let's just get this is
just a demo so I'm not gonna actually
pull in real data yet it's it doesn't
make sense for at this point which is
really kind of like more of a design
stage but I do want to grab the image
URL okay we are getting right now I'm
pulling the images from the current
database so that's all going to change
at some point for now it'll be okay
so let's change this image to this first
of all let's change the name we need a
title right yeah we're gonna need that
the title which would be the
students name we can see right away does
this image work right I don't care about
the larger screen for now okay that
image actually works for a card like
this great okay so there's the image
I think materiai has a title component
built in let's grab that component I
know I'm material I open somewhere on my
screen there it is so we're using
material UI's beta version if anyone
wants to check out the docs as well it's
material - UI - next comm to make this a
little bigger for everyone also I'm
gonna try and make this stream like kind
of a shorter stream because I forgot to
eat forget these lunch before the stream
I was just working in like on a roll and
so I know I'm gonna be getting super
hungry soon I've been waking up really
early so like 9:00 a.m. is like
lunchtime for me now so I'm definitely
past that that time all right where's
our card here it is all right so let's
check out oops yeah I want the demo so
let's look okay this is kind of what I'm
looking for a card that looks more like
this let's just check out a few other
examples yeah I think this one is the
best fit for us here so let's see what
else we're using all right so there's
not really a special component they're
just using typography headline okay that
that works fine let's just grab let's
grab all of this inside here
and copy it over just so you know in
case you haven't watched before I am
definitely going to get to you all your
questions in the live chat as soon as
this Pomodoro session is over so if you
if you are asking questions and I'm not
answering back please be patient and I
will answer all the questions in about
20 minutes or so car - okay let's save
that so we get the auto formatting what
you're not gonna auto format for me I
was pretty sure I had it all set up I
guess not
you know what I don't think I copied
everything that I call content actions
actions
all right the indentation just came over
really weird I'm gonna leave it alone
for now let's change this to be the name
though uh how you suppose are saying so
like if this year okay Noah Fisher and
let's grab a little bit of the content
that's here you know what let me let me
grab some of the content that actually
came through from the content management
system so when I pulled this in from the
database it had it already had some like
an excerpt basically already there hmm
looks like the excerpt has the name in
it as well
I don't like that this we may have to
manually go in and change this but I'm
gonna grab what was what was in that
excerpt out of WordPress that's on my
other screen and let's paste that into
here just for testing we can worry about
how we get that data in there later
I really think after looking at some of
this data I'm definitely gonna have to
have somebody go through it manually and
make some changes there's just not going
to be any way around it there's some
things that just I just can't work with
all right fr unipi great and then for
our buttons we're gonna make that's good
learn more yeah let's just leave a learn
more button in there for now
all right let's see what we have yeah
you know what I really don't like that
this is showing up like that I want this
to be more everything else I gotta
really like about that headline h2 why's
this let's check out why this h2 is
looking like really not like an h2 at
all all right sighs
did we change I'm wondering if we
changed something earlier I don't
remember this
I remember changing the size of this
let's see what it's supposed to be in
material you I was supposed to look like
yeah it's supposed to look like this
something's up I suspect maybe I just
changed something so let's check out our
code let me look at the live chat as
well to see if you all caught the error
okay it doesn't lose anything about it
in there right now
check up here
hmm
yeah I don't really see anything here
that would be causing that the only
place I'm even messing with font size is
here but I don't think that's that would
do anything there
yeah
all right well maybe I'll just switch
this up let's just try some different H
values see what changes if anything
looks like nothing Wow so an h1 ends up
with the same value
let's see
so I'm just checking the live chat
quickly yeah I'm not sure what's
happening with this we could certainly
just put some inline styles in here to
override this I suppose rather not do
that if I don't have to let's see what
we've done here
here's nine
oh yeah let's let's check out the code
for this next one down typography type
headline component that's exactly what
we wanted to do right very type headline
all right this is variant headline let's
go with type I'm not sure what the deal
was with the variant so if we switch it
to type though maybe that'll work there
we are
that's interesting
see I did have it does say variant
headline here that's weird
unless it's possible that this changed
in a very new version of material UI and
we haven't upgraded it yet I mean maybe
maybe we need to upgrade and then change
that we'll see I'm not interested in
doing that right now though
all right so let's see what you all
think then
so I don't know this doesn't seem very
eye-catching to me right now I am gonna
I'm gonna get on the end Rock server on
my phone so that I can see what it looks
like on a real device
let's see
i'ma send it to myself on slag
okay actually that looks a lot better on
a real phone
all right so here's what if you all can
look at this on your mobile devices I
think that would actually be helpful you
there's definitely a much different feel
looking at this on a phone than I'm
getting from here so I'm just a better
way to do it really happy for an grukk
right now although I know you can do
this through dev tools as well but
juggernut says good luck Jessie thanks
for the streams oh you're welcome thanks
for for all your advice you put in there
I mean shake my tongue all right we're
good it's been about eight minutes I'm
gonna go back to the live chat and
answer questions so if you just hang in
for a little bit longer I'll get to them
so here's a few things that I'm noticing
this text here could definitely be
smaller it's kind of overkill being this
large so we should definitely decrease
the size of that text at least for
mobile and then for this do you all
think it would be helpful to have some
sort of indicator that this is a student
profile right now it's just someone's
name we don't really know anything about
who this person is we have to read this
to get some sense and even then this
could be a like an alumni profile we
don't really know so let's think I don't
want to add too much onto here maybe
yeah maybe we can add something maybe
right at the top here maybe like student
profile and small like small font all
caps though in a different color
so I'm thinking maybe something like we
did for C eyes catechetical Institute's
[Music]
their resource cards so if you all see
that how we have you know obviously this
is the text we want people to see but
you can see here in a different color
you know just like I said all caps it
tells us what it is what category that
is let me know what you think about it
I'm gonna try to implement this then I
can't unfortunately I can't just take
what we did here because we used a
different system for this a different UI
system we use materialized CSS
it would be kind of nice if I could just
copy it over you know we did use it in
our bulletin project let's go to github
the react version of the bulletin I
believe did the same thing so let's
check it out
it should be under components and
attachments a little post preview I
think that's it so the post preview the
card view yeah here's our card view and
what did we do we are using material UI
ear typography caption okay so we use
typography caption and we did have some
styles we will pull over the styles as
well but see this is the benefit I think
I've talked about this before but the
benefit of trying to use a system and
stick with the system is stuff like this
to where we have these use cases that
are similar enough that we can just go
back to a previous project pull the code
and really get a jumpstart on what we're
doing all right so we're gonna copy this
first and then I'll bring the Styles
over oops wrong way so right here and
we're gonna change this for now we're
gonna say zoom profile and then we're
gonna pull over this category color
class we'll probably change the name of
it once we pull it over and now category
category actually works here that makes
sense area category color
I don't know where any the other the
other stuff is coming from it seems like
this we're doing some other stuff too
can I wear your color
oh we were doing category to uppercase
we yeah we can definitely change that
with with CSS alright so we'll change it
a little bit let's see
oops keep going the wrong way nice let's
change this to category and then up here
we'll add it in this category we're
obviously gonna change the color
we'll keep it like this for now though
and then let's go what is a text there's
a text transform let's check this out I
can't remember what the very value is
we'll see if this works
yeah that worked okay cool so it is text
transform uppercase so here we go we
have it here let me check on a phone
before I smell swith the size even on my
phone it's still a little small so I
don't want it to be too large but that's
that's definitely too small so let's
let's increase the font size slightly
see what we're working with right now in
terms of font size computer 12 pixels
yeah 12 is no good let's make it at
least 14 you know I really don't like
going much lower than like 18 or 16
let's just change it right here and see
let's see about 16 pixels see what that
does that's too big we're gonna have to
go to 14 the only other option is if we
made this title a bit bigger but I
really don't want to alright so let's
try 14 is the font size and see how that
looks on a phone as well obviously it
doesn't come through and dev tools we'll
have to add it to the code and save that
to see what it looks like font size and
got a comma and what do we say 14 yeah
and I definitely yeah I think I wanted
different color as well
student profile let me refresh okay so
that should be coming true now on my
phone too
to do anything
yeah I did okay cool all right I think
that's that's not bad I don't know how
many you can see it on your phone as
well but I like that I like that I think
the the font for the body of it could be
a little bit better and then we could
potentially put this in quotes so that
it's more obvious that this is Noah
Fisher talking
okay alright so my timer went off let's
take a short five-minute break i'ma go
to a live chat answer any questions that
you all have so I'm gonna scroll up and
start up near the top so the older
questions first
let's see there was some advice for kind
of that circle view that I had so I
don't think we're gonna go with that and
not that we won't use it somewhere else
but just for this particular case I
think I'm gonna go with this on a
desktop view I may actually go with that
circle view that that we had so I'm
talking about this I think it it works a
lot better when it's larger so we may
use that
nikki is asking about the HTTP sites
being marked is unsafe so Google
announced that chrome is going to start
marking sites unsafe that have HTTP
instead of HTTP so iniki's asking does
that mean that images also have to be
HTTPS like everything I believe so
so right now I think what happens is if
you're loading insecure assets on to a
site that's supposed to be HTTPS it
won't display like the full HTTPS
there'll be some sort of warning icon
for that so well it looks like John
Hanson already answered but yeah you
need to make sure all your assets are
HTTPS
blake ass if anyone's checked out react
ql you know what i read a little bit
about it but i haven't tried it yet
probably for this project since we're so
far along I'm gonna stick with Apollo
for the graph QL stuff but I'm open to
trying it out on other projects quanti
Xie asks if this is react yeah
definitely we're using react right now
so we're doing more of like the design
stuff so not getting heavily into react
components but we are working in react
components so you know this is inside a
react component we're using you know
styles as a JavaScript object which is
one way to do styles and react so
potentially this may be helpful if
you're learning react
let's see
I jog you're not saying I don't know
which what technology univer University
uses now but adopting two open standards
will allow University to share data
between services and systems more easily
avoid getting locked into specific piece
of technology or supplier reuse software
components built by others including
open source components reduce overall
cost of your digital service change your
services design every time we're easily
yeah okay so that's definitely the the
reason one of the reasons behind the
switch is exactly that I don't want us
to get locked in like we're we're
currently have been locked into a system
we're moving everything to open source
stuff and we're trying to use things
that like okay so let me tou is open
source we're using react which is used
everywhere our content management system
is WordPress but since we're pulling the
data in with graph QL we could grab data
from wherever we're not really locked
into that
also says looks good on the phone
checking on an s8 awesome alright Nicky
says rename the type property to variant
and material UI update beta 32 so you
are okay
so Nicky is it was confirming that it is
in the latest version of material UI
they did change that type property to
variant so where we were
I had this wasn't working for us that's
because I copied this from the latest
documentation and type is now variant so
whenever we do update to that we'll just
have to keep that in mind and go through
and change every instance of type to
variant assuming that there's no
backwards compatibility built in also
says maybe below the name as well yeah
we could do it below the name we should
maybe think about that right now
do you all think it would be better to
have student profile above or below the
name right now I I kind of would rather
have it above the name but if enough of
you disagree I can try to put it below
it wouldn't be that big of a deal just
to try it out let's see I'm almost to
the bottom of the live chat so I'm going
to glance quickly to see if there's
anything I should address right now okay
looks like you Yoshi knows if I'm
pronouncing it wrong please let me know
but I know she knows says above the name
looks nice to be honest awesome I mean
we'll probably just stick with that
alright one last question before we
start I arose in please let me know if
that's if I'm pronouncing that wrong
says what's the best IDE I use adamant
is is that meaning visual studio cut
better than these I use Adam and visual
studio code I like them both
visual studio code does seem to be a
little bit faster but if you have a good
computer it really doesn't make a
difference I have not used sublime but
I've heard it's good a juggernaut also
did a adopting open standards in modern
tech also attract future students
exactly exactly a juggernaut that's you
you definitely get like exactly what
like I've been trying to do here
gradually you know over over the last
two years that's kind of been my you
know trying to just update and move
things forward and this is kind of like
the pinnacle of that and finally getting
the main website off of you know this
old stuff so hopefully I can convince
everyone that I need to convince that
that is the way to go and we can get
this up and running soon someone in a
meeting like that I wasn't in threw out
a date of July June first I think of
June first there's no way we need till
June first to finish this site and I'm
afraid if we did take till June first
then everybody in the university would
want to have their saying and how things
go and we would just get swamped with
all these competing ideas but I'm all
for collaboration on that but sometimes
you can have too many people you know
putting their input in and then we'd end
up with a very cluttered kind of mess of
a site and that's not what we want all
right let's go
start our Pomodoro clock and all right
let's see okay I did want to try to make
this see how big we can make this while
it still looks reasonable and we want to
decrease and see how small we can make
this that it would still stand out all
right so let's check
inspect this right now and I'm gonna see
what they have 14 oh yeah I'd really
rather that be 16 pixels so let's see
what 16 looks like on here first oh yeah
for sure this I think 16 looks a lot
better let's try putting this in and
then on the phone let's see so component
Peas I think how I can do this what's
the best way to do this would be
for now I'm just gonna do it like this
and this will show a different way to do
styles and react sty and let's go with
whoops I did not need this font size
yeah 16 right 16 pixels okay so if you
want to do inline styles what did I mess
that up it's possible that I just messed
that up
I think it was just a style thing okay
so you can do inline styles like this
you need to use curly brackets to drop
in the JavaScript mode and then more
curly brackets to make this a JavaScript
object then you know just like we did up
at the top we're putting styles in a
JavaScript object so we use camel case
for our keys and then our values for the
most part you want to put your values in
quotes if it's just simply a numerical
value with no units you don't have to
put it in quotes alright let's see how
that looks great and that is coming
through like this I don't know that I
would want to leave this probably what I
want to do is maybe find some solution
where every component that has PE here
for under type with the typography
component would then automatically be
minimum of 16 pixels I don't really want
to figure out how to do that right now
with material UI but that's probably a
better solution that would just take
place across the board let's see oh I
want to look at it on a phone as opposed
miss Andrew there's one more step oh
yeah I yeah that is I don't know if you
all can see that on your phones if you
can that's just so much more readable I
like that I really like that I want to
see what it looks like in those quotes
as well so let's do it like that I
wonder for a second I thought what if we
do a blockquote right what about how
would that look maybe we can take a look
at that
yeah the quotes are okay I'm looking at
on my phone let me go over maybe there
is some other way to format this that
might look nicer but for now this I
think is acceptable let's adjust the
font size here so let's go with maybe 20
pixels whoa way too small all right
let's see 3030 is actually not that bad
yeah let's see what I'm using here for
this
typography display - yeah let's just try
to go with a different type here display
three maybe I'm not sure if there is a
display three but we'll try it out well
let's take this off - whoa displace
still too big display for okay as you go
up it gets bigger
let's try display one I was thinking
they were like age tags
okay all right display one is much more
reasonable let's just go with that
those will set it to display one let's
check it all these different display
values they're built in the material UI
so if you're not familiar with that
that's what we're doing yeah that's
that's much more reasonable and that
reduces the amount of scrolling
significantly great that's wonderful
cool all right now let's go we're gonna
try Nikki says plus one for trying
blockquote okay let's do that for sure
let's try block quote I want to see I'm
assuming that there's a block quote no
a scooter that typography component
we go to the API and check out the props
here we display four three two one
headline titles subheading body one body
two caption button maybe they don't have
all right so based on my three seconds I
spent searching it doesn't look like
there's a blockquote
component or option here so let's just
use the block quote element you know
straight up just the HTML element and
see how that looks
oh yeah okay so I'm going to do is copy
this and let's just put it over over
here this is kind of just my place just
throw stuff if I want to save it for
later and I keep forgetting to implement
the search well that's what this is up
here what maybe we'll do that on Monday
I think it would be cool to have the
search function available because that
that's the search works as you're typing
you automatically get results and that
seems to impress people so I'd like to
have the search function working as well
for our demos alright so let's take this
and say quote
chuckle die
let's see what happens okay so when we
make that a blockquote
yeah I'm not I don't think that really
adds much it's seems maybe like material
I doesn't have a blockquote
kind of built in let's see what I'm
saying
Brooke says just give it a left border
that's like gray I guess
before it was better okay yeah let's
switch it back actually I can just I
don't need to copy that over we'll
switch it back and then maybe we could
add let's add that border so you see
which all right yeah let's grab that P
let's do a border left and we'll go two
pixels two pickles might be too small we
might have to go three Bobble the two
pixels solid and let's go or G be a zero
zero zero and goes zero point five four
and that should give us a nice gray mmm
yeah it's too thin and the gray seems
too dark
so let's bump this down and go maybe
14mm twenty-four all right 24 and then
let's jump up I think four pixels might
be better yeah I like four pixels and
then let's give this some padding
padding left of eight pixels wonderful
all right what do you all think of that
so yeah so we've given a four pixel
border with a pixel padding the padding
goes between the border and the content
if we went margarine it would be on this
side so that's why we went with padding
instead let me let me put that in the
code and then you all can see that on
your screens or on your phones
let's make this a class now so let's
make a blockquote
class and classname classes let's just
call it quote I don't want to confuse it
with the element blockquote so we're
just gonna call it quote we can take
this out of here because we'll add this
in as part of the quote class quotes and
we'll just paste that in and then we'll
change it up font size 16 pixels
we're trying we need to camelcase
everything and put the proper wou
quotation marks get rid of the
semicolons and now this should work
let's go back here and great looks good
refresh great alright there we are I'm
gonna check this out on my phone I Nikki
that was a great idea I think I really
that adds something that looks nice it's
just a little thing but I don't know it
makes a difference let me know what you
all think I don't want things to be too
busy but really I mean this is gonna
this is really kind of a clean
minimalist site so I'm not worried yet
that it's getting busy but I I like it
I'm hoping other opinions though see
looks like so far so far everyone likes
it awesome Nikki again great idea on
that
cool alright cool and I did go with that
RG oops I just realized I had my phone
right next to the mic so I'm sorry if
there was any distortion in the audio
huh that sometimes happens when I have
my phone too close anyway so say I go
with that rgba because especially when
I'm trying to do black I usually don't
use it for other colors very often but
for black it's so nice to be able to
just you know on a scale of 0 to 1 being
able to adjust the you make different
shades of gray essentially you know by
adjusting that is just really nice and
then you know there are certain values
that I use consistently this so like
usually for gray text for alt text I
don't use regular black I use you know 0
0 0.87 and then for text that I'm using
in a form like the little hint text you
put in there and in like a form element
like an input that's iu 0 0 0 point 5 4
so those values are always consistent
throughout all the sites that I do for
the university so there's there's some
consistency and then you know for little
elements like that obviously we adjust
you know but for at least for the font
it's very consistent alright great
the only thing we didn't really do
anything about was this learn more but
you know what I like that it's coming up
with the University Green already which
which i think is fun that looks good and
so on I'm okay with that
all right let me check my timer alright
about eight minutes so at this point
what would be nice to do would be to
pull this out into its own component
potentially add in some some options
right so we would want to have the
option to change this type here this
category right so that we could use it
with multiple things so maybe we want to
use this as a faculty profile or an
alumni profile this component could
definitely work for all of those we
could also have options potentially for
more buttons and we definitely want this
button to be a link as well so we want
this we wouldn't leave it just like this
we would want to put a link component in
here yeah for sure those would be
options and then we could just fill in
the data you know as we pull it in from
from WordPress we had another suggestion
to try out okay so nikki says maybe we
can remove the quotes and Ahmed says we
could try italic let's try it out right
I think I don't think I have time to
really you know take on a whole nother
component before my my timer runs out
but I we do have some time to try out
some of these piece ideas what do you
all think about the idea to take out the
quotation marks would it still be
obvious that this is a quote if we take
them out now that we have this let me
know what you all think because I'm
definitely open to taking them out I
don't think they really looked at great
we could maybe add something a little
bit more stylish like an icon to denote
I'm thinking like maybe like a larger
you know quotation mark I don't know
like I said I don't want this to get too
busy all right let's try there's a
fright Alex there's a text-decoration
thought oh no it's not is it
all right John says take out the quotes
yo she notices italics might fit and
make the marks look better if we do keep
the clothes all font-style it's uh I'm
sorry I'll met you you typed it right
there I don't know what I was thinking
filling font style all right oh let's
just check that out sorry let me get
this down to one area
all right what do you all think
oops I didn't put it in there let me put
it in so I can see it and we can all see
it on our our devices so class quote
all right I'm gonna give you all a
chance to look at it and let me know
what you think before I say what I think
about it
I'm gonna check quickly about
I wonder what's the is there any
anything within material design that
designates when italics should be used I
don't remember seeing anything in the
documentation I'm scrolling through the
typography section right now seeing
anything
hmm
all right so here's my impression I
think it looks nice it makes it even
more obvious that it's a quote but it
makes it less readable so I think we
have a trade-off here
do we want to sacrifice some readability
or
or have it look I don't know I'm a
little bit I'm torn between this let's
let's do this and you check my time oops
alright only have a minute left let's go
down here
alright so I'm gonna remove italic from
here and I just added an inline so we
should be able to see both both versions
did it not work I did something wrong
oops I put it on the wrong wrong thing
okay now we should be able to see him
together and on different devices
I can't decide I'm gonna leave both my
timer just went up so I'm gonna leave
both of them one for now and I think
I'll probably even commit these to
github like that as well we can worry
about refactoring into another component
sometime
some other time or if anybody really
wants to make a pull request you know
doing that then that's that would be
great as well but maybe I'll show my
boss or show it to some people around
here too and get their input hmm sorry
sorry about the yawning okay I'm gonna
go back to the live chat go through and
finish up if any questions that I missed
from from the last break and then I'll
wrap things up here
on Hill says why not work with pixels
and why work with pixels and not
percentage it would be better for
Responsive actually yeah I would like to
have the responsive text so basically
what I want is a minimum that the text
will never go below which is going to be
like 16 pixels and then it could get
larger from there so I'm open to doing
that I mean for now which just was
easier for me to use pixels and I mean I
pretty much think in pixels I'm used to
using pixels so I know in my head like
here's how this will look with the other
units that I could potentially use I I
just can't see in my head what that's
gonna look like so when I'm doing things
like this I'm always in pixels but I'm
open to doing other things you know when
it's time to actually you make the final
version of this
also says what if you put the name below
the text on the right side and remove
the italic text all right so it would
look more like like the citation for the
quote I think about that I'm not gonna
try it right now because you know at a
time my time I ran up but I'll keep that
in mind is an alternative what I'll
probably do is show these to my boss too
and if it looks like he's not that
excited about this design I'll bring
that up as an alternative to
okay all right I see y'all were talking
more about putting it below yeah yeah I
think about that anything
yeah I'm wondering just from like a
marketing standpoint would it if you put
the quote with a small name below it
then the quote itself is highlighted and
the name is in a secondary place if you
put the name at the top with the quote
underneath in the name is higher up I
think like if we want the student to
identify with hey this is another
student like a real person to say
student profile and then a name makes
that immediate connection and then they
could read more if we want them just
though to connect more with what the
student is saying and just know like hey
this is a student then the other way
around would work better I like to think
about that because I mean I could see if
the quote was really good or or profound
you definitely want to highlight the
quote I don't know that that's
necessarily the case with all these
quotes maybe also the quote is is kind
of like large I'm gonna think about it
I do agree that putting the name below
would definitely make it more evident
right away that it is a quote
hmm
this would be a really good thing to do
for a be testing I potentially have
multiple versions of the homepage where
we have one with this style and and
another card with the style with the
name below and then we measure how many
people click on that learn more button
one that says with the name below it
would make it like a testimonial
actually you're you're right really what
we're doing here is a testimonial maybe
we should look at some common design
patterns for testimonials and see if we
can get some ideas how this is it like I
could we could spend so much time on
this one component really at some point
I have to make a decision and say okay
we have to move on
Sean saying more graphical quotation
marks yeah I think I could be a good
idea
all right I'm gonna think about these
ideas if anybody would like to mess with
this component and you know just to try
some things out feel free if you do want
to make a pull request for something
like this I suggest not removing these
but just adding another one like add a
third one with the alternate design so
that we could compare you know one after
another I'm also gonna have to think
about given the limited time I have
before I have to present this is it
worth it for me to worry about this like
longer term yeah for sure I think so and
I think it might be worth it to do the
a/b testing but before my presentation
would it be worth it for me to worry
about this I don't know that I have time
so I guess I'm gonna leave it at that
point for now but I really do appreciate
all the input because I don't think I
would have thought about those things on
my own
okay
yeah and I this is going to be really
prominent I think this type of component
will be prominent it will be important I
definitely want to measure clicks on
this this is a really good candidate for
a be testing yeah so I'm going to go
with that I think at some point probably
not before we I do the presentation but
potentially before or like shortly after
we launch I think I want to do another
version of this taking into account your
suggestions and then test the impact
that's really the only way to know which
one is really gonna resonate with
prospective students who more alright
cool
let me commit this right now so I don't
forget and then you all can have access
to everything that we've done in the
repo so let's do it get status see what
we've done great that's exactly what we
modified so no surprises there we do it
get add and then we'll do a yarn CM this
is something like custom that we have on
this project that it walks you through
the pattern of making a good commit
message so it's going to ask us if what
this is a new feature yeah this is a new
feature let's say let's see create
create component for student profile
card great
actually that's kind of misleading I'm
gonna leave it there but we didn't
really make a separate component because
we didn't pull it out yet into its own
file but I'm not gonna go back and
change it right now we did not break
anything and we didn't have any issues
open so all our tests are gonna run our
linting is gonna run I don't know what
did we do HTML entities must be escaped
where is the set
oh it doesn't like the quote alright
let's just take the quotes out for now
then I'm okay with that
well I can change my message now all
right
creates even profile card all right
that's more accurate because we didn't
turn into a component just yet
there we go should pass this time
looks like Nikki wasn't a fan of the
quotation works anyway so now they're
gone
Noble and savage says forget what hi
Jesse tis Savage banana soup hey how's
it going thanks for joining us
all right cool to get was origin
Oh between last stream and now I also
did merge that next five branch with
masters so after I upgraded it again and
checked everything out everything was
working fine so I thought okay let's
just merge it back and now if you see
any weird things happening please let me
know but I think we'll be okay with it
for now okay Nikki says you can do yarn
cm retry to commit the exact same thing
messages and all it's better yeah yeah
that's really helpful because a few
times that's happened to me and I've had
to type it in again and it's really
frustrating especially if you get errors
like three times in a row which has
happened so yeah I'm definitely gonna
try my best to remember that and use it
so that is helpful yeah in this case I
wanted to change the commit message
anyway but thank you
Thank You Nikki alright so I think I've
gotten through everything and so I'm
gonna finish things up here and go get
something to eat thank you so much for
all your help
I think we made a really nice component
today I think it looks great
and then we also have some ideas for
some variations on this component as
well which is also awesome at the very
least it might not be a bad idea to use
different variations of the same
component on the page at the same time
just to kind of mix it up for people
yeah
yeah I think that would be good now that
I think about it we probably could get
some quotes from some more like famous
people like since this is a Catholic
school like we could probably get some
quotes from some bishops and stuff that
might be impressive to prospective
students or their parents and we could
use this for that as well so I could see
this component as being very useful for
a variety of you know different pieces
of content all right well it's Friday
have a wonderful weekend I'll see you
all on Monday